herr präsident meine damen und herren
zunächst mal möchte ich eine richtige
gute nachricht des heutigen tages hier
besprechen
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat heute
den weg frei gemacht für die
ratifizierung des europäischen
wiederaufbau programms ein wichtiger
schritt in der bekämpfung der pandemie
in ganz europa und gemeinsam
und er zeigt dass wir noch lange damit
zu tun haben die pandemie zu bekämpfen
nicht nur wenn es um die
gesundheitlichen folgen geht nicht nur
wenn es um die risiken für das leben
vieler bürgerinnen und bürger geht
sondern eben auch wenn es um die
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen der
pandemie gibt geht und ich sage an
dieser stelle noch einmal klar und
deutlich es ist richtig dass wir mit
enormen fiskalischen mitteln dazu
beitragen das leben in unserem land
arbeitsplätze und unternehmen zu retten
und dass wir es in europa gemeinsam tun
die lage ist unverändert ernst
und das will ich sagen weil man ja nicht
immer sicher ist auch alle das auch so
sehen
heute sind einige unterwegs auf den
straßen dieser stadt die sagen es wäre
nicht ernst es wäre fast nichts los doch
es etwas pathos 80.000 bürgern und
bürger dieses landes sind gestorben und
darüber kann man nicht hinweg reden und
auch nicht hinwegsehen
und weil die lage unverändert ernst ist
muss auch etwas getan werden über das
hinaus was wir bisher unternommen und
das was wir jetzt brauchen es klarheit
und konsequenz was ist wenn die inzidenz
werte wenn die infektionszahlen zu sehr
steigen und wir sagen wenn sie über 100
gehen dann muss etwas getan werden und
das gehört zu klarheit und konsequenz
dazu überall in deutschland und auch
immer und in jedem fall letztendlich
sind das die regeln über die wir jetzt
hier entscheiden und ich glaube dass sie
zur verständlichkeit für viele
bürgerinnen und bürger beitragen werden
und auch dazu dass viele mitmachen denn
das viele durcheinander hat ja auch dazu
beigetragen dass man sich nicht mehr so
sicher ist was zu tun ist ob das
wirklich richtig ist ich glaube mit
diesem gesetz werden wir noch einmal
eine neue große unterstützung bekommen
für all die maßnahmen die jetzt
erforderlich sind weil sie gemeinsam
vollzogen sind und eine angelegenheit
der großen gemeinschaft unserer
bürgerinnen und bürger sind das müssen
wir erreichen und das werden wir mit
diesem gesetz meine damen und herren was
dazugehört ist dass wir uns klar machen
dass die lage für viele nicht einfach
ist und das hat ja auch mit dem ernst
dieser lage zu tun den kindern zum
beispiel die ganz lange zeit die schulen
nicht gesehen haben die manchmal sehr
engen wohnungen mit sehr großen familien
leben sie haben verdient dass wir uns um
sie kümmern
sie haben verdient dass wir deshalb auch
sagen kind schulen werden zuletzt
geschlossen als erste wieder geöffnet
trotz all dieser strengen regeln aber
sie haben auch verdient dass wir in eine
chance für die zukunft geben das auf
pakete ist eine antwort darauf was
notwendig ist
und vergessen wir nicht unverändert sind
viele alleine und einsam auch das ist ja
mit den verschiedenen beschränkungen und
regeln verbunden und auch die haben
verdient dass wir schnell durch diese
sache kommen und dass wir deshalb mit
klarheit und konsequenz handeln und
klarheit und konsequenz sind auch
wichtig für die unternehmen die um ihre
existenz bangen
die sorge haben dass sie nicht
durchhalten bis zum ende der pandemie
und die jetzt von uns die botschaft
haben wollen wir haben ein kurs den wir
konsequent verfolgen und der dazu
beitragen wird dass neben dem
finanziellen mitteln wie auch ein ende
der pandemie zustande bringen und das
ist die aufgabe die mit diesem gesetz
verbunden ist und denken wir auch an die
pflegekräfte am die ärztinnen und ärzte
all diejenigen die in den krankenhäusern
in altenpflegeeinrichtungen jeden tag
arbeiten und dafür sorge tragen dass die
gesundheit so vieler bürgerinnen und
bürger geschützt wird sie können fast
nicht mehr sie schuften jeden tag und
auch sie haben verdient dass wir mit
klarheit und konsequenz handeln weil es
die voraussetzung dafür ist dass auch
dort einmal all diese anstrengung ein
ende finden weil wir es geschafft haben
werden das ist mit diesem gesetz
verbunden
meine damen und herren die entscheidung
die wir jetzt hier treffen fallen
natürlich zusammen mit einer ganzen
reihe von weiteren maßnahmen die wir
ergreifen zb dass die vielen neuen und
zusätzlichen möglichkeiten zu testen
jetzt auch ergriffen werden dass wir
sicherstellen dass tatsächlich überall
testzentren in deutschland eingerichtet
worden sind und jetzt verfügbar sind
dass wir sicherstellen dass in den
schulen zweimal die woche getestet wird
dass wir sicherstellen dass das in der
unternehmen der fall ist wie das mit der
arbeitsschutzverordnung geschehen wird
dass wir dafür sorgen dass das
home-office deutlicher durchgesetzt wird
auch durch eine neue starke regelung im
infektionsschutzgesetz alles das gehört
dazu und sicherzustellen dass die
hierdurch punkt und natürlich auch das
gehört dazu dass wir die hoffnung in den
blick nehmen die mit dem impfen
verbunden ist
denn tatsächlich machen ja die impfung
große fortschritte
der bundesgesundheitsminister wird es
ausführlicher darstellen da bin ich
sicher aber ich will ausdrücklich sagen
dass jetzt über 16 millionen bürgern und
bürger erstmalig geimpft sind das über
20 prozent der bevölkerung geimpft sind
das ist ein fortschritt jähriger wegen
seiner geschwindigkeit auch sichtbar
werden es dass wir eine chance haben im
sommer vielleicht einmal wieder in einem
biergarten zu sitzen und das ist die
perspektive die wir gemeinsam mit den
strengen regeln verfolgen ist es geht
nicht um einen dauerzustand es geht
darum die pandemie zu überwinden und
darum sind die regeln auch richtig
was wir darüber hinaus tun ist dass wir
natürlich sehr sorgfältig abwägen dass
wir überlegen was zu tun ist wenn die
lage sich verändert und deshalb ist es
richtig dass in diesem gesetz eine
verordnungsermächtigung enthaltenes über
die wir hier in diesem haus viel
diskutieren werden die abgeordneten
müssen zustimmen und das finde ich
richtig so über die wir diskutieren
werden mit den ländern in deutschland
was wir nämlich zu tun haben und was wir
tun wollen wenn es geimpfte gibt die die
möglichkeit haben bestimmte
erleichterungen auch zu nutzen
denn das ist die verordnungsermächtigung
zuallererst dass wir festlegung treffen
was geschieht mit geimpften was
geschieht mit denen die chinesen sind
was es mit den ihnen die tests haben und
dass wir das in einen guten richtigen
nachvollziehbaren vernünftig
diskutierten rahmen stellen und dass wir
den bald festlegen
auch diese erleichterung möglichkeit
gehört zu den strengen gesetz dazu sie
ist ebenfalls erforderlich und notwendig
und ein letzter satz was wir hier machen
und worüber wir heute beraten und wo was
sie heute hoffentlich beschließen werden
verehrte abgeordneten neun abgeordnete
dass es nicht frei gegriffen das baut
auf sehr sorgfältigen verabredung
zwischen bund und ländern die
unterschiedlich umgesetzt worden sind
die aber doch einen gemeinsamen rahmen
hatten und dass wir uns darauf beziehen
dass wir das hier in eine strikte
regelung umsetzen das gehört zu klarheit
und konsequenz auch dazu und das ist das
gebot der stunde
schönen dank
[Applaus]